hey you came back welcome back to myth
chasers the series which tests your
weird and wonderful questions in the
ever-changing world of fortnight Battle
Royale
if you have a myth which needs busting
throw it in the comments below and about
those you'd like us to waste our time
trying please think about using code
Adam are doing the star to support me
but liking and subscribing are just as
great if you'd be so kind that is far
too much begging for one episode let's
chase some myths let's start with a
simple one Marvel fandom asks what
happens when we use the pointed out
emote whilst using caps shield broken
emotes who doesn't love myths about
broken emotes this one is for you my
friend here's the point it out emote
with Captain America's shield cross axe
selected Oh oh dear it's totally broken
and I kind of love it if I'm honest what
about you ok on to the real stuff the
main question of this episode UFC guy
asks do Marauders use gliders it's
simple and effective as Marauders enter
the world from up high it would make
sense that they have something to stop
them crashing down to the ground and
being eliminated but how on earth could
we test this well we didn't have to wait
long because this person says this
what happens when Marauders go to steamy
stacks let's do this
I put out a call on my discard and 40 of
us jumped into a custom game and tracked
down a bunch of Marauders we slowly
tempted them towards the stack in a race
against the storm circle we got them
there but then we had another issue the
Marauder would not walk over the
evolution waters somehow he put one step
out of bounds and he started to fly but
it wasn't for long enough to see if he
popped a chute but then as the storm
took us the community managed to push
him over the edge one more time and here
it is a Marauder flying in steamy stacks
but will he pull his chute and there it
is a Marauder glider if you haven't seen
one before that's their glider that's a
far longer than expected to capture but
we got it and now we know for certain
Marauders can save themselves from a
deadly fall using glider redeploy hmm we
took this one step further and used
fishing rods and kits yet launcher to
double check this myth which led to this
moment here the Marauder was happy to
skydive constantly in steamy stacks he
didn't even move when the storm circle
engulfed us all and guess what we have
another myth to try just hear Tim the
tanned man okay I like what you did
there Gigi says myth Marauders are
immune to storm damage great myth I've
tried this before with a group of
marauders who outlasted me in the storm
previously but now we have the perfect
guinea pig we all watched on and waited
for the storm to take our lives our
brothers and sisters pop to one by one
they were eliminated we healed as much
as possible and just when the myth
looked to have been proven the Marauder
went bang so we learned that Marauders
do take storm damage but it's far less
damage than compared to Jules and the
other bosses in the world
interesting stuff next myth fizzle
Wizzle on discord rice what happens if
you lead Marauders to the whirlpools at
first I totally misread this and simply
throw a Marauder into a whirlpool it
does this if he didn't know but then I
reread the myth leader Marauder we must
tease the Marauder into going into the
whirlpool under the wrong volition once
again we've worked as a unit and tried
for the biggest whirlpool there is we
lost many players in this pursuit but
finally one Marauder swam into the
whirlpool and this happened
[Music]
Wow once again he saved his own life by
using a glider and even continued to
eliminate us all after landing back down
these Marauders are legendary warriors
next myth please boy fat let's break
from Marauder myths and instead bring in
a challenge
68 419 asks how many work benches can be
stacked up oh so we're making the
Leaning Tower of Pisa out of work
benches okay I'm cool with this once
again I throw out two : discard and we
all jumped in and one by one we began to
stack the upgrade benches and if you're
wondering anyone can join me in these
meetups I'll link the discard below I
just do these at random with whoever's
online anyway we all searched the island
and joined back together in the final
few circles our first attempt was going
so well look at the size of this beast
really impressive until someone
accidentally broke down the tower when I
asked everyone to remove the builds
around the tower and you totally ruined
my life thank you so much but it's okay
mistakes were made that we're made of
sterner stuff so we tried again and
check out what we built a total of 30 in
one stack 30 upgrade benches this is
officially a world record I'm told GG
everyone who took part but is it
possible to beat this
whether you use battle labs or a public
game I challenge you to beat our world
record and this goes out to any other
youtuber to the grenade community
challenges your community to beat our
erection but words but you get the idea
good luck you're gonna need it ok back
to those Marauders let's quickly finish
the Trinity of challenges sub to me asks
will a Marauder use a launch pad this
one is a super simple one for us all
we knew that Marauders wouldn't
deliberately jump on a launch pad
without being coerced so I forced them
to follow me across a sky bridge then
when the Marauder was perfectly above
the correct spot
I let him drop ok I totally missed and
messed up completely and deserved to be
knocked myself with me out of the way
the grenade family did this for me
because I'm useless they were able to
test this mate
from two different heights from lesson
one tile above and then six tiles above
and both led to the same result the
Marauder
uses the launch pad and safely deploys
their glider to land and continue the
chaos I feel like we've learned a great
deal about Marauders today GG everyone
so dynamic fire is now at our fingertips
in four night from the flag on to the
fireflies and this has led to many
questions and myths and then this one
caught my eye Rasputin 88 states the
water balloon emote puts out fires what
this must be too good to be true so I
jump back in again to see if we had a
pay2win emote in fortnight we can't have
can we for this one the grenade farm
hunted down flare guns fireflies and
Matt's and meta and we had our snowball
and water balloon emotes ready to go I
chose these because these are water and
snow or ice and they explode on impact
could that help we then set up two
important buildings worth saving watch
both made of wood we also had people
ready to die inside hood watch like real
Patriots with the first Hut watch I use
the fireflies and we immediately
attempted to put out the blaze only
using emotes yeah that sounds really
silly when I say out loud well check out
the results an absolutely huge mess a
massive ell this did not have a chance
and I'm kinda gutted if I'm honest I
would have loved to see emotes as an
actual mechanic in-game but like we said
that would create a pay to win scenario
with those who have the emotes and those
of us who don't so this leads to the
second Hut watch tons of you guys asks
if we could check out the Chuck splash
myth is it true will Chuck's blushes put
out fires we set up the exact same
experiment and once the fire took hold
we threw our beverages
and oh wow
almost immediately puts out the fire it
is no more hot watch is saved huzzah
hashtag I've watched for life okay let's
finish our work on the Marauders the
final one of the episode myth Marauders
won't attack disguised players and won't
find you if you hide in a bush so a
double myth here what do you think will
Marauders looking bushes to find us and
can we walk past the Marauder wearing a
disguise I'm not convinced so let's try
this yesterday a new group of people
jumped in from the discard everyone
except me put on a disguise it's three
to choose from around the world everyone
then walked over to the Marauders and
well you've guessed it already haven't
you
everything failed here every one of them
was shot meanwhile I decided to stay in
a bush and to my surprise it worked
the Marauders walked straight past me
and didn't give me another thought but
here is the main thing to be noticed
once the Marauders find a target they
will be completely focused on them until
another person shoots or hurts them so
realistically the Marauder wasn't
bothered that I was in the bush it's not
that he didn't see me it's that he
couldn't care less about me
Kendyl and my parents to double prove
this point one of the disguise players
never shot a single bullet at the
Marauders and he was left unhurt for
many minutes so it may look like it's
possible to hide or disguise yourself
from Marauders it sadly isn't though you
will get hit eventually so myth busted I
think that's enough myths but one day
we've chased enough today thanks to
everyone on my disk God who helped out
really appreciate it and thanks to you
if you're still here now on screen are
more than leggins
who are kind enough to rock my cold a
tomorrow in the star and then send me a
DM on Twitter less details in the
description if you want to join the
leggings roll call next time I'm Adam
from Playstation grenade and it's been a
pleasure and guess what we're starting a
new tradition we're gonna finish the
video with a dad joke are you ready what
did the late tomato say to the other
Tomatoes don't worry
I'll catch up
[Music]